benoît martin est en direct il est
secrétaire général de l'union
départementale de la cgt paris laure
martin bonjour merci de répondre à nos
questions comment est-ce que vous
accueillez l'annnonce du conseil d'état
satisfaction bien prudents quand même
puisque comme le dit l'exécutif c'est
juste attendre encore un peu alors les
deux quelque part mais c'est qu'ils
savent en vous une bonne monde réel que
quand on est une substance pour cette
réforme de l'assurance chômage
et puis c'est vrai que c'est un peu ce
derby ou pas les choses pour le show
parce que là en liquide c'est mauvaise
conjoncture et que se confiera plus tard
donc c'est pas ce qu'on demande l'on
demande vraiment un retrait de la
réforme
c'est une réforme qui avait été mal
engagée déjà des débuts si vous avez
vous déjà en novembre dernière 2
novembre 2010 par le même conseil d'état
avait déjà retoqué plusieurs mesures de
cette réforme après s'avère travailler
entre des gouvernements le patronat et
les organisations syndicales ça devait
entrer en vigueur au 1er avril a été
repoussée 1er juillet et l'alien nouveau
intention de lever par cette décision du
conseil d'état
donc ça montre bien que au delà des
aspects des couvertures mais ce n'est
pas le moment c'est que cet argument qui
est valable et la quasi totalité des
organes crédit qu'elle dit et c'est une
réforme très injuste et crédit ne l'aura
compris hein vous à la cgt puis les
syndicats vous estimez que c'est une
réforme qui va faire baisser des
allocations pour les demandeurs d'emploi
d'emploi le gouvernement assure que non
et évoque une réforme plus juste sur
quelle base est ce que vous appuyez pour
étayer vos arguments quelqu'un qui
travaille un technicien qui
2000 euros par mois dans l'intérim après
son intérim s'arrête
et puis le voilà dont il entre aux
unités de l'indemnisation du chômage
et puis quelques jours à peine avant le
15 juin par exemple la boîte d'attirer
des libéraux qui retournent au travail
etc et donc tu vas travailler pendant un
mois du 15 juin au 4 juillet par exemple
et donc le fait d'être à cheval sur un
divan et le mois de juillet est de
travailler quand même à mois consécutif
ça me faire s'écrouler tout les droits
alors que quelqu'un qui travaillerait le
soit moins un joueur seul tout en
juillet seuls au relais la plénitude de
ses droits non ce sont déjà des loin
diminue donc c'est une réforme qui
techniquement ne tient pas la route a et
donc empruntant de gouvernement qui ont
été entendus un conseil d'état avait été
totalement approximative dans ses
explications
alors que les enseignants syndicats
l'ont fait vraiment des simulations ont
fait une équipe n'a pas que l'unedic
aussi elle même a fait une étude
d'impact il dit tout cela était dit
arabe inédite par nantes mais des
sources syndicales au gouvernement comme
concepteur gourmet bancal c'est vraiment
de l'amateurisme et donc le gouvernement
persiste en m6 conseil d'état a suspendu
l'application pour l'instant vous parlez
de l'unedic justement à explosion des
dépenses recul historique des recettes
l'unedic prévoit 19 milliards de déficit
cette année et une dette de plus de 65
milliards fin 2021 il ya quand même
urgence à réformer non non non il ne
faut pas baisser dans des initiations
des chômages où il faut travailler sont
allés romancée et les transitions
énergétiques à réussir il ya une du
numérique généralisée dans dans dans la
vie des entreprises et des français en
général il ya plein de deux sources de
grandir deux des factions de sens
économique
il faut une politique économique et
recréer de l'emploi et pour nous ce
n'est pas en diminuant
l'immunisation du chômage on va résoudre
les choses car les chômeurs sont des
hommes et les femmes qui sont également
des consommateurs s'ils n'ont plus les
moyens de payer leur loyer de faire les
courses etc
comment ça va se finir sa vie ou en cuir
dans l'en but lillois est expulsé des
logements il n'est pas en plus
consommées il faut maintenir et vous
donner une idée sont corrects pour les
ceux qui sont créées en quoi les
objectifs de la réforme du système reste
pertinent et atteignable selon le
ministère du travail qu'est ce que vous
répondez au gouvernement
non c'est nous avons fait la
démonstration à part une équipe de
technique sérieuse que cette cette
réforme est très injuste et qu'il ya des
cultures d'égalité alors qu'ils aient pu
tout à l'heure un exemple la façon dont
le mode d'acquisition des grands
d'indemnisation chômage puis dans le
parasite et de ses droits quand il ya de
fortes inégalités et donc heureusement
il y a l'intersyndicale qui est unie et
puis également l'unedic en qui sert un
peu de rempart contre cette réforme
totalement injuste et donc s'il y a le
conseil d'état n'a suspendu pour
l'instant puisqu'il s'agit ici en photo
narré par référé rallye maintenant sur
le fond pour obtenir le retrait
définitif
justement vous ne tournez la perche
c'était la dernière question que je
comptais vous posez puisqu'il faudra
encore attendre quelques mois pour voir
le jugement du conseil d'état sur les
recours des syndicats sur sur le fond on
le rappelle un seul la cftc n'est pas là
l'ensemble des syndicats sont sont
présents là dessus qu'est ce que vous
attendez donc sur le fond d'ici ces
prochains mois donc
eh bien nous attendons jeu réforme soit
retirée contresens une réforme de
régression sociale et c'est vraiment
double même pour tous les gens qui
quittent père bloqués en raison de
l'actualité perdu leur emploi ou vont le
perdre bientôt non aux suppressions
d'emplois en ce moment dans de nombreux
secteurs et on est très touché à paris
notamment
je prends le pari est donc non ce qu'il
faut c'est continuer à indemniser les
chômeurs à peu près correctement
et puis relancer la machine économique
on a quand même un ministre du plan qui
est censé donner des perspectives de
relance économique
il ne sort pas grand chose de ce plan je
trouve
merci benoît martin d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire général de l'union
départementale de la cgt à paris